you look stunning you look gorgeous
thank you have a team of magicians back
there yeah what's that are people
working yeah when fussing with you
literally I shocked your producer he was
like wait you you look different than
when you arrived and I was like what
that's why you pay the big bucks out
there so that's so nice you know what's
my best for you it's so thank you thank
you very much that's nice I like that
attitude let's get word out there see no
I really am stunned sometimes because
sometimes I see the guests show up and
they're where they're backstage and
there's they're wearing sweats yeah
sideways baseball cap and they're
spitting tobacco and then then they come
out here and they're wearing this just
amazing knockout outfit and it's it's
what America actually needs to know
because it's you know we got to keep it
real yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna send a few
selfies and when I wake up yeah that's
not great really it's special yeah I
look exactly like I sleep with makeup on
yeah my roommate hasn't get to makeup
put on for work which it's new now to
him he loves it he really feels good in
it we should probably explain what your
husband's former major league baseball
player Nick Swisher I think we have a
photograph of him there he says he gets
makeup for work now he does an analyst
he's an analyst on television so yes he
gets the makeup on yeah he like notice
your suits we talked a lot about your
style out here so we've got you know
we've got some work to do okay yeah it's
City he's in backstage right now so he's
oh he notices what we're wearing yeah we
get the best clothes from Sears it is
working we you know we talk I got to
mention this because we talked about
this lat you mentioned last time and it
it kind of freaked me out
your dad's an ob/gyn yes and that you're
you revealed that your dad delivered
your first job dead and your entire
audience was horrified well I don't know
if they were horrified it just kind of
blew everybody's mind it's such a weird
thing you made me feel so good about it
that's what I'm here for
it's bad cop good cop
yeah no you were great too but I
remember you looked at me Ike
unfortunately I was talking about my
vagina why and it was embarrassing and
you looked at me and said what's the
family business and you just made me
feel so good thank you right of course
we shouldn't be ashamed of those things
oh I wouldn't I don't think you should
be ashamed of it at all no no it was
Tara it is terrified but it's a very
strange experience and you were saying
vagina a lot drives at home a little bit
yeah I wanted everyone to know exactly
where it came from
but it opened a lot of doors for me I
gotta tell you the stork show up for two
all right I've had two kids until you
assumed yeah because I'm Irish you
doubled it together we've had four yeah
to get well we got your husband's here
Nick's gonna come out just lay into me
you